For the sixth day of Christmas we've gone
with carbon, element number six and a
particular sort of coal, called anthracite, which
is almost pure carbon. This is a sample
of anthracite that was sent to me by a
YouTube fan called David Harris; I think in
Pennsylvania. Anthracite is really, looks
rather beautiful, it looks almost like
bits of metal. It's very light and it's
almost pure carbon. I think after
Christmas we're going to get Neil to burn some
of this, but David also sent me some ash
that is left over from the burning. Some
of it went into the bottle, I put it into
a bottle, but one piece was just too big
and what's interesting about this ash.
which I think was burnt in a furnace,
is that it's very light. I think these
are just bits of minerals which were
included in the lumps of anthracite
and they didn't remove properly. According to David that anthracite
with almost a colorless flame. So again,
that's something which we can test in
a future video. And although it's coal,
it's not at all dirty. I can rub it on my
hand and you can see none of it comes
off. So, for the sixth day of Christmas
element carbon in anthracite, a glowing guitar plectrum,
four drinks containers, three chemical badges, two periodic table bed covers,
one piece of tartaric acid from a Swiss wine barrel.
And let's see what's number seven.
[Prof. Licence] ...gas we get out into our pipe.
So this is really for safety because the pressure inside the cylinder,
is a lot higher than the pressure that we
require
in our reaction or inside our balloon.
[Prof. Poliakoff] So this is my present for the first day of Christmas.